[Music]
while the amazing world of gumball was
originally created for kids it became
significantly darker after the second
season stick around to see which
nightmare-inducing episode claimed the
number one spot of inappropriate gumball
moments if you're new here hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video and don't forget to give us a big
thumbs up let's check out 10 the amazing
world of gumball episodes that weren't
for kids the storm let's start with the
episodes that made one particular scene
go pretty viral after someone watched
the show and realized just how creepy
this innuendo actually is we all know
all cartoons come with innuendos but
you'd never expect it from a show like
this in the storm we see Allen the
balloon and Carmen the cactus breakup
gumball finds Allen crying in the school
bathroom and tries really hard to make
him feel better this is when things get
a bit weird Allen says he doesn't have
the strength to inflate and be cheery
which could might as well be in a new
window
he even Wiggles his head to show what he
means of course if you're too young you
probably won't even get this but we bet
a lot of adults wondered how this
managed to even make it in the cartoon
show and in the next scene we see the
two leaving the bathroom stall Allen
looks happy and well inflated while
gumball looks like he's just done
something he probably shouldn't do at
his age just look at gumballs face it's
one of the weirdest innuendos we've ever
seen on the show and it certainly wasn't
meant for kids the remotes since so many
young kids watch this show there's a
good chance they might learn a few
things from the storylines however not
all lessons are positive the remote is
the first episode of season 1 but the
ending of that episode features a creepy
scene we hope no child would ever want
to learn from at the end of the episode
the four-year-old on a nice locks her
whole family outside just so she could
watch her favorite show she seems very
pleased with herself that she was able
to pull this off while the rest of the
family seems pretty worried outside
while it's a cute idea
we hope that no child ever tries to pull
this off because it's really not safe on
top of that ah Denise plans all of this
out in order to get the family to stop
fighting over the remote so she could
watch her favorite show we have a
feeling plenty of kids feel exactly the
same way but we really hope none of them
attempt to do this themselves and lock
their family out of there
or even out of the room just so they can
watch their favorite show not to mention
it's totally dangerous for
four-year-olds to be left alone in the
house the job this entire episode is
just bizarre at the beginning of the job
we see Nicole acting pretty bizarre and
having a nightmare
and later a breakdown when she realizes
her husband has a job when we were
watching this scene we definitely felt
creeped out so we can't even imagine
kids watching the same thing Nicole's
bad feeling about her husband's job
makes you wonder what's going to happen
richer's reckless driving is probably
considered hilarious by a lot of people
but we hope no kids think this is how
you actually drive gumballs neighbors
are also pretty bizarre especially mr.
small who passes out from a fake
vegetarian pizza for a few seconds it
seems unclear whether he's still alive
which is just a little bit too
inappropriate but seriously Nicole's
mental breakdown is one of the
highlights of this creepy episode that
definitely wasn't for kids besides she
wants to stop her husband from having a
job after they've realized his job is
causing weird shifts in the entire town
the entire car ride is also pretty
creepy as is the music as many people
have pointed out some gumball episodes
should never be seen by kids and the job
fits that description Halloween let's
face it every Halloween episode is
creepy regardless of what the show
actually is Halloween scenes just allow
characters to make the cartoon slightly
more scary than usual the shows like
gumball took it slightly too far and it
starts right at the beginning when the
kids take a shortcut through the
graveyard why would they ever do that in
the first place here's the actual
problem we have with the Halloween
episode gumball and the rest of the gang
go into the graveyard house but because
any East is too young to go they just
leave her hanging on a tree yes you
heard that right
she's just hanging on a tree and they go
into a haunted house and then there's of
course Carrie the ghost who makes
gumball and Darwin drink the potion that
turns the entire place into a scary
party house and it gets even creepier
when gumball and Darwin turn into ghosts
and their real bodies just drop down of
course Halloween episodes are meant to
be scary but this was just a little bit
too much especially since the show is
meant to be a kids show and let's not
forget to mention that the scary
Halloween party has way too many
dirty innuendos the flower we told you
that this show gets extremely dark in
season two and all other seasons after
the flower starts pretty innocently with
a cheer scene and gumball and join the
side of his cheerleader girlfriends
Darwin was pretty hilarious by keeping
it real in the first scene but what
makes this inappropriate is gumballs
jealousy at Leslie being with penny
instead of him this episode was meant to
show the actual effects of jealousy on a
person but seriously they took it just a
little bit too far gumball becomes a
completely different person and honestly
it's pretty scary while it's true that
this is what jealousy actually looks
like it's just a little bit too much
seeing gumball basically having two
personalities while Kari and Darwin
seemed pretty scared even the school
staff seemed horrified by gumballs
behavior this is definitely one of the
top creepiest episodes that definitely
weren't meant to be watched by kids
eyeballs seriously the jealous version
of gumball is way too mean and his voice
is way too scary for kids and then
there's the scene where gumball forgets
but penny is an actual live being and
starts ripping off her puddles to see if
she actually loves him the verdicts in
and we made a decision that this is just
way too creepy the fan the amazing world
of gumball also touches on an
interesting topic no child should ever
know about let's start with the
beginning of the episode where Darwin
and gumball runs so fast they completely
forget about the dangers of the
neighborhood not to mention they're
super rude to Sara and even knock her
over on purpose at some point but what's
even more inappropriate about that is
Sara who becomes just a little bit too
creepy and not just with her bad puns
Sara is a stalker Sara thinks both
gumball and Darwin are totally in love
with her but when gumball says she's the
insanely obsessive person she excitedly
accepts this assignment she seems to be
always there and she even admits that
she sneaks into gumballs room and
watches him when he sleeps she also
explains all the places there are to
hide in their house and also mentions
the lack of security pretty creepy right
she doesn't even seem to have her
preference for neither Darwin or gumball
she just wants one of them to be her
husband this is definitely a totally
inappropriate episode for kids and if
they watch it they should be explained
that there's nothing funny or
entertaining about being stalked and
breaking into someone's house the joy
you've probably figured out by now that
the amazing world
gumball is a really special show and we
bet not a lot of adults wouldn't want
their kids to watch it but don't worry
we're not done yet there are a lot more
gumball episodes that are just a little
bit too weird for our liking the joy is
just way too bizarre at the beginning
Darwin and gumball are getting pissed
because it's Monday their dad gives them
a hug that makes their entire house
explode but it gets even weirder after
being miserable both gumball and Darwin
become way too happy and it's pretty
weird they start singing musicals
they're totally obnoxious and they're
disturbing their whole class
gumballs laughter is also pretty
psychotic and definitely not the type of
laughter you'd hear from an actual happy
person
gumball also tries to stop smiling but
ends up ripping his mouth from his face
miss simian also makes the whole episode
look like the Blair Witch Project by
recording this weird phenomenon and when
gumball and Darwin are on their hospital
beds they make themselves laugh so much
they end up looking completely lifeless
let's face it this entire episode
including the ending where the students
are being chased isn't really
appropriate for kids the signal the
amazing world of gumball features plenty
of episodes where we see the town
malfunctioning because of strange
reasons but the way this town
malfunctions in this episode is strange
even for this show in this signal which
is the 24th episode of season 4 we see
gumballs strangely glitch as Darwin
tries on hats it almost makes you think
the actual episode is glitching we feel
like this episode is totally overly
complex for cartoon designs for kids
when Darwin gets upset over gumball he
tries to become stronger to fight with
him in one scene he ends up dropping the
barbell on his face during a bench press
which is definitely every weightlifters
nightmare but what's even creepier than
that is the way their world is glitching
the way Darwin's face practically melts
in one of the scenes is the weirdest
thing we have ever seen and we hope no
child would ever repeat Richard's car
jokes because they were actually pretty
hilarious and then of course it goes
right back to the bizarre car scene
although the episode has a sweet moment
between Darwin and gumball the entire
glitching and switching between the
different scenes makes it just a little
bit too creepy and confusing for a show
that's meant for kids the scam the
amazing world of gumball didn't feature
just one Halloween episode in the fourth
season we get to see another Halloween
moments that's even scarier than the
first it all starts with a Halloween
show-and-tell at school gumball tells a
scary Halloween story and for some
bizarre reason he changes it into the
monster he's talking about and just like
that he changes back into gumball like
nothing happens we all know this show
has its weird moments but it seems like
the kids got more scared by the story
rather than the fact of gumball can turn
into a monster once he finishes the
story carry the ghost helps him
manipulate things in the classroom to
make the kids feel more scared we see
Suzy's dress being lifted up and a human
face being revealed underneath and if
that's not scary enough it turns out
that gumballs monster was actually real
and he looks even scarier than the
monster gumball turned into at some
point gumball Darwin and Kari were
almost eaten by the creepy drooly
monster but it turned out that he just
wanted a lot of candy even though this
episode had a happy ending it was way
too scary for something that was meant
for children the night and now let's
move on to the very final gumball
episode that sends chills down our spine
the characters of this series tend to
dream about creepy stuff and that's
exactly what happens in the night the
episode starts up with a dark fairy tale
voice that starts putting everything and
everyone to sleep and explains that will
now explore people's dreams
it starts with gumball getting a weird
feeling he's falling when he's asleep
but then he realizes he's in a dream
then we see mr. small in a tiny room and
if you know mr. small you know that he's
claustrophobic which means he's
definitely freaking out we also see
banana Joe snapping in half after trying
to eat his own head the bizarre episode
shows characters in what seems to be
their worst nightmare and it's
definitely not pretty but the creepiest
dream of all belongs to Anais who
becomes a doll while daisy the doll
becomes a live being along with the
terrifying music in the background it
also seems like Daisy is trying to drown
and hurt her even though Anais always
make sure she treats Daisy well and the
fact that Daisy comes to life and
whispers that this was her dream is even
stranger seriously this show is just way
too inappropriate for kids and that's it
for our video don't forget to subscribe
to our channel and hit that like button
for more videos like this one
see you next time
[Music]